all right ladies and gentlemen we got
the story from timcast.com President Joe
Biden tells Americans to have confidence
in banking system as additional Banks
fail Silicon Valley Banks and signature
Banks were both taken over by the
federal government amid collapsing share
prices I also want to point out that for
some of the uh images we use on
timcast.com they're AI generated just
look at how horrifying this is like this
picture of bank run has these people
screaming but it's like the jinji Ito of
of bank run AI generated images it looks
like these people are being hunted down
by some Demon that's stealing their soul
as the uh Banks collapse but anyway I
thought that was funny
the federal government took control of
Silicon Valley Banks a top Bank in the
tech sector on March 10th after its
share price Plum rapidly plummeted New
York Regulators announced on March 12th
that they have taken control of
Signature Bank known known for Real
Estate lending and serving clients tied
to the crypto currency industry quote
the bottom line is this Americans can
rest assured that our banking system is
safe your deposits are safe Biden said
during a press conference with the White
House on March 13th let me also assure
you we will not stop at this we'll do
whatever is needed oh boy
I love how when uh East Palestine has
this massive chemical spill he doesn't
even show up he didn't even mention it
okay he mentioned it don't get me wrong
but there's no bailouts they don't care
about the people who live there but when
Millionaires and billionaires in Silicon
Valley have their woke Tech sector
threatened he comes out on TV and says
at nine in the morning of all times Joe
Biden waking up at 9am saying we're
going to take care of this nothing to
worry about here's what I think
I hate
I hate to go on a show with as many
viewers as this and be like the end is
nigh or something like that but
Joe Biden has to come out and say this
he has to because if he doesn't there's
a run on the banks and if people go on
TV and say anything other than
everything is A-Okay then there's a run
of the banks so that's the default
position of every personality and media
whether it's true or not I don't know is
to come out and pretend like
everything's gonna be fine yeah it
doesn't make any sense because your
bank's insured for 250 000 per account
so 99 of Americans Banks can fail FDIC
they're insured you have nothing to lose
so it's amazing to me that Biden is
panicking and doing the stuff for the
ultra Rich you have more than 250 000
first so for Silicon Valley Bank he's
just helping out big tech companies and
Rich investors in big tech companies
because normal people who had deposits
at Silicon Valley Bank have nothing to
worry about most people don't have 250
000 sitting in a checking or a bank
account they had nothing to lose yep and
so they're going to be doing is
apparently the FDIC c will cover
deposits above 250k and I apparently I
guess BuzzFeed had all their money in
Silicon Valley Bank well now I'm really
encouraging no bailouts yeah
bye-bye they shouldn't it doesn't
benefit us it hurts the normal people
because that means Federal government's
bailing it out that means more debt that
means more inflation that everyone
including poor people will pay and this
is just a move to help rich people who
have more than 250 000 in big companies
and Banks it makes no sense to be doing
this well there were like I was
listening to a space today most of the
day I was listening to spaces and just
trying to wrap my head around what's
going on and from what I can gather is
the biggest worry is Contagion to other
Banks so we've got two of the biggest
bank failures in in American history
happening over the course of the past
weekend I
I am of the opinion that if if the
government's the government's going to
bail uh bail everyone out or the bail
the banks out because the government has
basically taken responsibility for any
any failures in in the banking industry
uh you know they've bailed out
everybody every time that there's been
any kind of well any kind of the rich
Elites
I mean to be fair they did they did do
all they they printed a lot of money and
whenever the government prints money and
it goes to the people it ends up with
the big Banks and the big corporations
anyways because everyone gets that money
and they spend it it's not like people
go and they sit on it when they get if
you get 500 bucks from the government if
the government when the government you
know was passing out cash people didn't
sit on that and it was enough money to
change anyone's life or or that they
make it you know that they're going to
invest with it anyways so that money
just ends up in the big corporations
hands anyways because people spend it so
it's just it's they're just going to
continue to print money because that's
what they have to do so when they get
together again when the FED gets
together again instead of doing 50 basis
points it's likely they're going to do
25 it's possible they're gonna do zero
and then they'll see what happens I
don't know what's going to happen
between now and then obviously but
they're gonna take the break off of the
off the raising of rates because they
can't have the rate I can't keep uh
interest rates uh keep raising interest
rates the way that they are with this
kind of this kind of monetary situation
in the U.S or they want to provoke loans
to the banks basically so the Bannon
asked me on Friday Steve Bannon why it's
a Ponzi scheme this economic system that
we're in and I I gave him like a half
answer I said that it's because we're
borrowing money from the our banks our
institutions our government is borrowing
money from the Federal Reserve and then
promising to pay them back with interest
the only way to get that interest is to
borrow more money from them at interest
to pay back the interest which now we
owe interest on the new borrow so we
have to borrow more to pay back the
interest on the edge and uh the real
Ponzi is when what happens is that money
goes to the banks then the banks loan
out to the common American to for
mortgages and then they have to pay the
interest they push the interest down to
the small guy sort of and so all this
whole system is banked off these 40-year
interest payments by American people
constantly paying more than they
borrowed to fund this Federal Reserve
usury well I mean it's it's it's sort of
to fund that but remember like when you
are getting a mortgage you're buying
you're getting a house too so it's not
you pay the debt it's technically owned
by the bank until you pay them back well
yeah but you get to live in the house
it's not a one-sided operation is what
I'm saying right I understand what
you're saying that it's frustrating that
you have to pay uh pay more than the
than what you're borrowing but that's
why the banks are in business so that
way like they'll lend you the money you
pay them more than they actually lended
you that's the business model and let's
let's let's let's let's talk about it uh
seriously a lot of people they don't
like International war and things like
that a lot of people they don't like the
Petro dollar they don't like imperialism
they don't like big bank bailouts but I
I believe for the most part not
completely but for the most part these
are the evil things that these evil
people do that does have a positive
effect for a lot of people in this
country that is when the US Military is
setting up military bases in foreign
countries and pointing guns at people
and saying use the US dollar or else it
creates demand for our currency and then
we don't have to do as much work and if
the petrol dollar collapses then we're
gonna have to go back to chopping wood
and raising chickens on our own and
actually producing things in our country
something most Americans aren't prepared
for and don't want to do most Americans
that are young now they're just
demanding free that's really many free
stuff
Ken clippenstein today was tweeting
about about uh
forgiving student loans like today
because they're talking about bailing
out Banks the banks that if you bail out
a bank you're bailing out a bank because
people had money that they put into the
bank so that's completely and totally
isolated from like the the situation
with student loans where people didn't
have money they borrowed money they got
an education ostensibly and then then
they're asking to be forgiven for that
for that borrowing money well you're the
one you're you're getting the
forgiveness for the education or for the
bar
it's the excessive compounding interest
that is the problem they used to call it
that's fine but that's not the same
thing as forgiving the loan in totality
correct that's different yeah I don't
know I'll hardly ever advocate for just
deleting people's loans I think that's
kind of dumb but like the idea the
profiting mechanism of loaning money I
get it it was a risk if I loan you a
hundred bucks there's a risk you'll
never show up again so I've got at least
like give me 110 back that way if I loan
out 10 times and one of those guys walks
away at least I made my money back but
it's excessive compounding interest debt
upon debt is like it's easy it's almost
incapable by the common American mind it
is the the issue here is how our whole
economy is one big Ponzi scheme from the
get-go that is unsustainable and going
back to 2008 we can clearly see there's
holes in the system they put a Band-Aid
over those holes but the water is
spraying through the ship is sinking and
now we're seeing it's it's like that
cartoon where the holes are popping up
in the hole in the cartoon characters
putting his fingers and his toes and his
eye or whatever you're not going to stop
it I'm but here's what I want to say
bailouts okay if you want to sit in your
lounge chair and watch sports and Order
nachos and drink beer and not have to
worry about anything you want the
bailiffs you want it all if you are an
entitled gen Z or gen Zer or Millennial
who wants to wants to go to college for
gender studies you want the bailouts and
this is why you are seeing the default
liberal and left us be alike we need to
make sure we take care of this because
then they prop up the system that allows
them to do nothing me I kind of think we
need to go back to a little bit of hard
work I'm not saying everybody should go
work on ranches where they tend to
chickens and goats and stuff like that
but maybe just a little bit because
right now we got a bunch of like that
viral video of the Gen zero being like
why do I have to work to live that is
burned into my into my brain and it
makes it work it's just let the banks
fail then they can go be like I'm hungry
like well start picking food yourself
it's grow your own food and check
chickens or whatever
Biden says that no none of these losses
will be borne by the taxpayer he tweeted
that seven hours ago for the record yeah
he said we'll pay for it from the fees
the banks pay into the deposit Insurance
Fund now I understand wanting to bail
out 250 000 of uninsured a lot a lot of
95 of the accounts in this Silicon
Valley Bank thing were not insured so
all those 250 000 accounts are gone but
they're decided to bail them out I
understand bailing out the small
investor or companies up to 250 000
correct no I again if you had 250 you
had less than 250 000 in that bank or
any Bank you have no risk you're covered
insured they all are not uh yeah they
all are the only ones who are getting
bailout are the ones who are Beyond 250
000 so there were big tech companies
that this Bank invested in and people
invested money in these companies and
the spank did too so we're bailing out a
bank because they're huge big payoffs
didn't work for them and they failed and
it's back just like we did in 2008 we
invested in tons of taxpayers money to
bail out Wall Street firms who had huge
Investments and derivatives making
billions of dollars of profits for the
people working in those Wall Street
Banks of zero value to American citizens
but you know Goldman Sachs the the
treasurer of Secretary of Treasury that
time so former Goldman Sachs CEO and
Federal Reserve people Goldman Sachs and
other Wall Street firms and the
government and the Federal Reserve full
of people from Wall Street bailed out
Wall Street at the expense of the rest
of the citizens you know the too big to
fail argument and that's what's going on
here the same way only in this case
you're bailing out banks that did bad
investments in tech companies and tech
companies that make big donations to
people from both political parties
that's who's getting bailed out this is
not to help you know low-income people
with 250 000 you know bank money in
there this is just people at the bank
making big Investments that are getting
bailed out from this unless citizens
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com com
for uncensored members only shows
exclusive thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next time